I
don't know what to do
stupid things that you're doing and
that's a good start because it starts to
clear your,
so if you,
if you don't know what to do but you do
know that you're doing things that maybe
regret,
you could start by just eliminating it
slowly to the basket of your
started to become ethical rules.
Seven ethical rules with any live
long enough,
then you'll get this,
but we have a clear vision and then you
might be received the way forward more.
You might see a way forward for more
intensity rather than merely what you
should avoid.
So that's a good initial practical issue
is because everyone knows perfectly well
that there were things you were doing.
You know you shouldn't do it,
but you don't stop.
Start stopping
because that's part of this idea about
putting your house in perfect order
before you criticize the world because
there's a question.
It's always open and that was the
question,
so to speak,
that God placed in front of me is like,
well,
how do you get on the road?
Would be a terrible place.
He weren't such a wretched thing.
Maybe it wouldn't be.
You might say,
well,
that's very casual answer.
What would you say?
The people who has a parent who's dying
of Alzheimer's disease for example,
it's like whether they're going to get
their act together and fix that.
It's like it would make it a hell of a
lot better than it would be.
Otherwise.
I can tell you that,
and that's something because it's nice
to have someone who's dead and your
family without having a credit of
unnecessary pathology.
Gather around that and make something
that could be nearly tragic into
something that sounds right and that
happens to people all the time and so
even if it's not a perfect solution is
the best solution that you have and then
the next part that is when I suggest to
people that they do the future authoring
program and they're.
They're leery about doing it.
I asked them to do that because a bad
headline is way better than no plan
because if you implemented that plan,
then you learn why that plan.
Exactly.
Not Hypothetically,
but exactly in the world and then in the
news that information above your failure
to retool.
A better plan and so to be able to
manage,
if you're tracking a destination that's
moving,
it's some kind of ideal you,
your vision is blurry,
you don't know where to look and so
you're going to go this way and then you
can go this way,
but if you keep doing that,
then the deviations from the right path
to decrease with time and eventually
you'll be walking forward in an
efficient manner and you might have to
be all sorts of errors before you
managed that,
but I've watched people long enough in
my clinical practice to know that
waiting for Godot was a very bad idea
and not employee.
That is a very bad idea.
It's like implementing the best plan to
have a camp
and learn from her and that works and
you get sharper at making your planners
and then the other thing that we do in
the future authoring program,
the school,
we asked people,
well maybe you can decide what your
passion for your calling you should be.
That's a pretty global question,
but you might ask yourself some
questions like,
well,
is there something you could do to
improve your interpretation ship?
One thing,
is there a way that you can improve your
friendships?
Is there something you can do at your
job that will make it better than it is
now?
Even if it's something you preventable?
Could you do something more productive
and meaningful with your time outside of
work?
Could you be slightly better handling
temptations that come your way?
Could you take care of yourself?
Something like better mentally and
physically and you know the answer is
all of those questions is Jennifer.
Yes,
and then you can even ask yourself a
simpler question which would be,
oh,
if there is something that you could do
that would make one of those things
married,
is there also something that you would
do and you can ask yourself that you
know instead of telling themselves that
you should,
which isn't the same thing might say,
well,
I would like my marriage to be better.
You can ask yourself,
well,
how can my marriage be better?
And you'll get a bunch of answers and
most of them you will,
because if you really ask myself a
question like that,
the part of their brain that's imagined
and it's looking for new answers will
tell you and it looks like a bunch of
things you don't want to hear at.
A lot of them will be things you already
know and some of them will be things
that there's just no damn way they'll
give you know that you should,
but some subset of those might be things
that you should do that by your own
definition that you actually would do.
It might be trivial things in or hooked
trivial,
but at least they're a step in the right
direction.
So take whatever step in the right
You're willing to take day by day and
that's incremental progress and it'll.
It'll spiral upward.
It does spiral up,
or there's a statement in the New
Testament,
which actually happens to be a true
statement,
which is to those who have everything
more will be given and it's a reflection
mind phenomena that looks like
phenomenon that looks like a natural
laws.
As things start to accrue to you,
the rate at which they will further
approved will increase.
That's a natural logs.
Price's law sometimes with the court
parade reflect greater distribution,
so there's a chapter in 12 rolls,
life called don't compare yourself.
Compare yourself to who you were
yesterday,
not to someone else's today,
and it's in conjunction for incremental
improvement.
If you don't know where to go in your
life,
think about where you are and see if
today you could make where are you,
are somewhat better on some dimension so
that when you go to bed at night,
you're not as wretched as you were when
you woke up in the morning,
and so if you do that for two years,
it was one thing a day,
just a small thing,
something you could actually do that you
would do,
then your life will be waived it and at
the end of that you might have enough
clarity of mind to start to understand
where you go if things worked out for
you properly in the world.
So that's the answer.
That question.
Thank you.
All right.
Here's another way that you figure out
how to act.
Let's say your child and there's a lot
you don't know almost everyone,
so how do you handle that?
Will you stay in a simplified
environment,
right?
You don't crawl out onto the street with
your 10 months old.
Parents aren't allowed to do that.
They keep you in a bounded did and they
keep you close to them and what you do
is backed up what you know isn't very
much most based on things in your mouth
and investigate them because that's what
kids do at the smiling play,
that it's a fragile space of knowledge
and it's easily when it's disrupted,
you cry and not signal of disruption and
then your parents move in with greater
knowledge and they fix whatever the
problem is and what you do.
As you watched that and then you have a
job.
It's not like you don't let the rep
count because you're not sophisticated
enough to know what they're up to.
No child childhood give a full account
with the behavior of their parents.
Know parents will give a full account of
her own beginning,
so you certainly can't expect that from
a child,
but children are obviously grow up to
take care of their own children,
just like image to take care of their
own offspring,
never knowing what they're doing.
Exactly.
So you learned about your invitation.
Now what that means is that collectively
we faced things that we didn't
understand for very,
very long period of time and we've
figured out how to act so that it works
out.
We don't know.
We don't know the rules that underlie
that exotic.
We don't know exactly what that means.
We just figured it out.
So there's A.
There's a way of being a good father.
Let's say there's a way of being a good
mother and mostly you understand what
that is.
When you fail or when your child accuses
you of failing gap,
right?
Because it's only in the failure,
but you realized that you deviate for
whatever the ideal is because you're
not.
Who the hell knows what the rules are
for being a good father?
It's very difficult to detail though,
but you know when you've failed.
Okay,
so you know how to be a control and you
know that because you invitation to your
father,
he and his father and his father,
and it's like way back as far as you can
possibly go.
That's the goal.
We also know that.
Here's.
Here's an example of why having a clock
call colleague at the University of
Toronto who spends in maternal behavior
in rats raptured actually very
sophisticated.
They have somewhat of a culture
statement pass on through imitative
learning.
If you take away from.